to present the award for our direction
and set direction we call on a lady who
decorates any set in which she appears
and the gentleman who is an artist in
the finest tradition of the British
theatre she can be currently seen in
farewell my lovely and he will soon be
seen in the bridge too far
actually I'm a Cornishmen and mr.
Anthony Hopkins is our Welshman and from
a Cornishmen to a Welshman that's a hell
of a tribute anyway miss Charlotte
Rampling and mr. Anthony Hopkins
good evening ah for the best achievement
in art direction the nominees are Ken
Adam and Roy Walker for Barry Lyndon set
direction by Vernon Dixon Edward Capano
for the Hindenburg set decoration by
Frank McKelvey Alexander trona
and Tony Inglis for the man who would be
king separate decoration like Peter
James Richard so that and W Stewart
camel for shampoo set decoration by
George Gaines Albert Brenner for the
sunshine boys set the record in Azhar
can Adam and dry water for Barry Lyndon
unfortunately the winners can't be with
us tonight but if they were I'm sure
this must be one of the greatest moments
of their lives thank you to present the
nominees for best achievement in costume
design the Academy wisely turns to a
star who wears clothing with style has
impeccable taste a profound knowledge of
line color fabrics fashion and who can
get it for you wholesale and one or two
other things as well here is that chic
Greek Telly Savalas
Thank You Bobbi baby just to prove what
a fashion Authority I am I was clever
enough to have an expert stashed away
backstage he already we all patted over
her pictures in Vogue and Harper's
Bazaar they stayed in as you just
finished the film the innocence by
Visconti joined the party miss Jennifer
O'Neil